[Music]
everyone coming out to my talk very nice
to see all of you I feel like we cut
attendance by half from the party last
night so you guys are all troopers so
this talk is normally called down the
SVG rabbit hole there's a lot of things
that we go through this is going to be
what we're gonna end up with this is all
inline SVG is the only piece that is
external on here is a CSS fill with a
hex code value it's one of my it's it's
one of the coolest things ever and
nobody uses it and it blows my mind that
nobody uses it
these were graphics from a project
called pro gaming League they're now
called millennial eSports they build
they service like online gaming
companies I'm not a gamer like Halo and
League of Legends and all that fun stuff
so for all the gaming nerds we built
these really fun animations for it so
I'm a former nuclear engineer turned
front-end developer I have a really
crazy story to tell you about that you
can ask me later I work on the
international growth team with a company
called Shopify we are coming to Germany
so shameless plug if any back-end devs
are looking for e-commerce stuff come
and talk to me after or one of the
recruiters Julia she's here she gave a
talk yesterday I also run a business
called zona Fitness Academy it's an
online e-learning platform for fitness
trainers I live in a tiny mountain town
in the middle of nowhere called
Revelstoke it's about an eight hour
drive from Vancouver but none of you
know where that is
so I just stay Vancouver it's better and
I am a Sports adrenaline junkie and this
was our pet bear that lived in our yard
for about seven days in in a tree fun
fact
okay so today we're gonna be going I'm
just gonna start at baseline so that
everybody here kind of has an
understanding of where we're getting
started with SVG's how many of you use
SVG's in production right now how many
of you have like you feel like you
stand each of the attributes that are in
an SVG element okay so this is why we
started a baseline from there we're
gonna talk a little bit about the bones
of our SVG and just talk a little bit
about collaborating with designers so
that you can make this less painful
because this process can be generally
quite painful for developers if they
haven't if they're not working with a
designer that really understands what
they're doing and exporting stuff from
sketch or illustrator I'm gonna talk a
little bit about my fed SVG workflow and
then we're gonna get into the guts of
the actual talk which is the super cool
SVG animations that you saw at the
beginning so when you're working with a
design team you want to make sure the at
the beginning of the project you
determine what your goals are actually
gonna be so if you want stagnant or
animated SVG's because this will totally
change your fed workflow and it'll
change the amount of time that you want
your designers spending in in their
sketch files so for this reason you want
to communicate really early on in the
projects what your primary goals are
gonna be so today I'm gonna talk a
little bit about exporting from sketch
just so that we have a baseline of that
so when you guys go back to your design
team you're like hey you're doing this
wrong so you should probably do it the
right way make my life a little bit
easier I am NOT gonna be talking about
exporting from illustrator because
there's a lot of really awesome online
tutorials and there are great resources
for that I am however gonna talk about
what it looks like when a designer will
send you an SVG and sketch so I realized
this is illustrator there's a screenshot
of illustrator but I wanted to kind of
just elaborate on the point that is a
really ugly piece of code this is by
default what it looks like from your
designer it's totally unnecessary okay
all of those nested files so for every
single layer that goes in here this is
this is exactly what the like default
exports gonna be when you come out of
sketch so there is this great command
line that you can put in and restart
your computer for your design team and
it will take out a large portion of
those ugly guts that you just saw you
can write that down but the slides are
tweeted out so if you want that you can
take a look at it there's a company out
of New York called thoughtbot this is
what they use for all of it but it
essentially just creates a compact form
of the SVG it's a little bit nicer so
let's talk about exporting SVG's from
sketch so within sketch we have this
infinite canvas and so what happens is
the SVG element itself will have
transforms and translates attributes
attached to the actual SVG and so for
that reason doing really advanced
effects can be difficult because you
also have to take into account the
already existing transforms and
translate so if you have this infinite
canvas and you have this like small SVG
on one specific point within that canvas
that generally is not very helpful and
so what you want to be doing is actually
creating in your own art board for the
SVG itself then you're gonna take and
select the layers within the the panel
from there you're gonna take and flatten
everything flattening just takes and
merges the pathways that you saw so each
of these small elements on here will
have specific paths or an extra element
in indented into the SVG and so what we
want to do is make sure that when we're
using the fill on it that it's all
within one single element and so doing
that process takes what you saw on the
left to what you saw on the right and
that's a pretty nice piece of code to
work with it's kind of more readable
HTML you know I I like it it's easier
and so this SVG is literally just the
clothes
imagine that X that you have on every
single modal every single like form
element whatever you want to call it
this that's like that's a really simple
icon it shouldn't be that complex and so
what happens is now we have one folder
with two elements so we have two paths
which are respectively each side of the
X so I'm gonna skip that so let's talk a
little bit about SVG's for beginners
generally this is how the the SVG's are
defined you have something called a
grouping you have your IDs your strokes
and so for every single group orgy
element within an SVG that is a folder
respective to illustrator or sketch and
so we want to remove a lot of that
nesting the other thing that you'll see
in here which is like kind of messy is
this transform and translate piece that
I had talked about previously this is
literally sketch taking and moving that
element where it is within the infinite
canvas on the page and we don't really
want that because that will that adds a
lot of variable or variations when we're
taking and doing a lot of these crazy
animations and then you have each of
your actual elements or pathways now
these numbers and letters they all mean
something I'm totally happy to have a
discussion about what they mean but it's
kind of just how the browser will read
read the elements so what we want to end
up with is a really succinct form of the
SVG so we have the view box which is
essentially the artboard of the element
so wherever the element lives on that
actual page so imagine you have a canvas
that's 33 by 33 and the starting point
is at 0 0 which is the top left hand
corner and from there it goes across the
canvas and so by definition we have a
grouping take which is the folder that
contains everything and then we have two
pathways so this first pathway is that
first cross of the stroke and the second
pathway is the second cross of the
stroke and that's it that's like a
simple X icon it's a little this is
literally just so that you guys have a
baseline to understand like how our
SVG's set up so let's talk a little bit
about SVG optimization so there's this
awesome tool called SVG oh I'm sure that
most of you use it if you're doing crazy
animations I wouldn't really recommend
it they have done a significant amount
of work I'll explain so unless you took
the time to go through all those steps
that I talked about within sketch
SVG Oh actually will prevent you from
being able to modify the SVG in the way
that you need to later on so you can use
SVG oh and do these animations and
effects later on but you want to make
sure that it's within its own artboard
or within its own canvas because
otherwise you have these transforms and
translates attributes attached to the
SVG pathways or to the SVG elements and
this will cause a discrepancy within the
animations and it will actually prevent
you from having it accessed on multiple
browsers so again
beware of SVG oh it's good for like
icons and like if you're doing really
simple stuff but if you're doing more
complex animations I still to this day
will edit SVG's in sublime or like in
your text editor because otherwise
there's there's too many variations and
you have to start back at the beginning
this is another fun little snippet of
code that I love so generally as a
front-end developer you'll define a lot
of your base lines just like you would
with the image iframe and video element
you also want to add SVG to the max with
a hundred percent as your defaults and
the reason why you want to do this is
because you don't want the SVG to be
exploded outside of its parent container
this is just one of those things that I
always add to my base files okay so I'm
gonna talk a little bit about some like
cool how to's that you can actually have
so the beautiful thing about SPG's is
you can define it once within the DOM
and you can utilize it across the entire
project okay so imagine you have social
icons or you have logos this is like a
very standard example of how you can use
SVG's and so we had a project not that
long ago where we had social icons
defined in the footer we had social
icons to find in our profiles and then
we had multiple versions of our logo
depending on where it was and so each of
those items are only defined once on the
page and so you have that pathway of
letters and numbers that defines the
actual shape of the element yeah so you
can utilize this awesome element called
you
within your SVG where you define the
pathway once and you can target which
element or icons you want to utilize
with an ID and the use tag and so that
allows you to define the SVG once and
use it everywhere and so what ends up
happening is you have a really long
piece of text or like a really long
piece of like SVG code that will allow
you to take and target each of those
items so in this case like you can see
in the top left hand corner the little
like lightning bolt icon you can see
that it's used in like quite a few
places and so what happens is I have
that pathway to find once and I can take
it target it just by calling an x-linked
href and so that correlates to an ID
that's attached to the pathway or the
group within the SVG and you can use
both then you can take an out of fill
color you can add like width and height
attributes if you want the same thing
goes with how I'm utilizing all of these
SVG badges or like these skull badges
that you see across the entire site and
the other way to do this as Wally's with
a lot of these like social icons which
is also a pretty standard piece so I'm
gonna take and see if I can find this
lovely piece of code so I can show you a
react project that we did not too long
ago
okay so can you guys read that okay or
do you want me to increase the font size
okay so in this in this file we're
defining a component called social icons
you can see within here we have like the
angellist icon we have a twitter icon
with a grouping and we have a social
Facebook icon durable etc etc and so
these pathways are only defined once on
on the actual page within the Dom and so
I pulled that into the footer and I can
take and Target it throughout the entire
project on any given page so what
happens if I is like is I give it a
width and a height of zero and it sits
it like lives on the end within the Dom
but you don't actually see it unless you
call it with those pieces of with those
pieces of code using the the use element
so I can take and target it the same way
where it'd be like social - Twitter or
social - Facebook and these are one of
the ways that you can take and actually
reduce the amount of code that you have
within within the page and so that's
just one of the fun ways that you can
utilize SVG's so let's get into the like
actual guts of the the talk the like fun
stuff I don't know about any of you I am
like a super math nerd so there are
matrices in here there's cubic Bezier
functions or standard deviations it's
awesome so some of these filters and one
of the cool things that you don't that
you won't actually know on this this is
the exact same SVG element and the only
thing that I'm plying that's different
on here is I'm either adding a fill
color or I am not applying a fill color
at all so by default SVG's are black
within the within the Dom if you don't
apply a fill color of any kind you're
gonna get that and so the reason why
this like you can see on the top right -
the reason why they're white is because
I'm applying a white light effect to the
SVG element itself and there's no 3d
effects but it's literally the exact
same piece of SVG code or pathway that's
defined once and then you can just take
and apply these effects these ways
so if you want to jump into code pen
there is a code pen so you can take and
play around with any of these there's
two versions of each of them there's one
with G SAP that uses it and then there's
one that utilizes the inline animate if
you go some blur like all of the inline
SVG elements so you can use for these
elements so this is the baseline okay so
we have a class set we're applying an
inline style with a fill color you can
do this within the CSS as well we're
defining the view box which is really
important so on here you'll see some of
the effects that are created where the
view box needs to actually be a little
bit bigger because of the glow effects
that you have otherwise you'll hit the
the corners of the box and you don't
want that to happen and then what's
happening is I'm targeting that really
really large SVG pathway I'll show it to
you after if we have time so the same
way that you would take and define your
definitions within the SVG you would
also take and apply the filter element
within that in line so we're gonna go
into detail a little bit for this and so
this particular SVG doesn't have a fill
color on it okay it is by default no
fill there's no style applied to it all
it's just this code that's in here and
so what you can see within this is we
have a filter where we're defining the
spotlight so the reason why I want to do
that is because I want to take and
utilize the user like the filter element
that you need to apply to the SVG itself
so what happens in here is you take and
define the ID and you give it a name
with the filter effects that you can
take and apply it across and so in here
you take a go son blur and so I'm taking
the original the original element and
I'm calling the result of the original
source graphic after you take and apply
this effect so I'm going to take and
create a blur effect with a standard
deviation of two okay from there I give
it a result and call it blur one then I
take that initial blur one and I
put it within the the new lighting
effect that I want to apply as well and
so I'm creating a specular exponent
light so the specular lighting effect is
literally just this light that will take
and open or close as if you had a narrow
or really wide light that you want to
apply to anything across here so the
same way that you would a spotlight in
normal like think of it in that same
context then I'm giving it a lighting
color of just off-white because that's
fun and then I need to tell the SVG
where in the box so imagine you have
this 3d box and you have the SVG on this
one space I need to tell it where within
the x y&z planes we actually want to put
this light so I can put it really high
up I can put it right in front of it I
can put it really low and so you can
take and like imagine this 3d
dimensional box that you have and just
take and apply that same filter effect
to it then what happens is I need to
take the original source graphic then I
need to take the all of the effects that
I had applied to this and I need to
squash them together because otherwise
you have this really blurred you have
this really blurred SVG and by applying
both of those together and creating
these layers it's the same way that you
would take and apply layers within like
Photoshop or illustrator you just take
and pile it on top of one another and so
then I will take the original source
graphic I put it in and then I take the
the result from from the specular
lighting effect and I squish them
together there's Anna rhythmic equation
that's applied to this I'm also happy to
talk about that a little bit later but
for now we're gonna open up this item so
you guys can see it so one of the things
that I really like to do is remove this
source graphic so that you guys can see
what happens so by removing the source
graphic you actually you have a much
more distinct piece but by adding it
back in you can see that there's like a
more defined line on here and so
the lighting effect will actually take
and apply it across the entire ecosystem
and then if you want to you can take in
decrease the specular exponent you know
actually widen the light for you so as
you increase the specular exponent the
the more narrow the light gets and the
difference of the fact that you'll see
[Music]
okay so I talked a little bit about the
FE exponent piece so that really big ass
piece of code right there that's
defining the the skull it's massive it's
because of all of the points that are
within the vector itself in order to be
able to squash this and just apply
everything to a single SVG that's the
effect that comes from it okay so we
talked a little bit about the source
graphic now we're gonna talk a little
bit about the glow effect so I don't
know if you guys can see that it is
glowing right now essentially what
happens in this particular SVG is we'll
just create this a little bit bigger
okay now you should be able to see it
going in and out a little bit quicker
okay so this is you guys can see that
okay so this is a pretty complex example
what happens if I take away this
original source graphic is it just
creates this like really blurry effect
on it so you can see why you would want
to have the two layers merge together in
order to create create that actual
effect and so I'm just gonna go through
all of this code right now so we have a
we have an
called glow where we're defining the
actual filter that we want to apply to
the SVG then we are calling that same
URL within the SVG parent element
I am also applying a color fill with
this like blue hex code okay so the
actual element that we're creating here
is we're taking and applying that glow
effect we're applying a standard
deviation of 50 so that that 50 is just
how far away or like how much of a how
much we're actually going to be blurring
the the element itself and so the higher
that you go it's zero to a hundred that
you can be using the higher you go the
more blurry the image is gonna be we're
taking that initial result sorry I can't
like see where my mouse is there we go
so we're taking that initial result by
applying that effect and we're calling
it spec one from there I want to take
and apply the animate the Elm animate
element and I want to animate the
standard deviation so I want the glow to
create this pulsing effect and so by
targeting the standard deviation I can
tell it to go from zero to fifty which
is the standard deviation that we
defined in the original parent goes on
bluer element then I'm gonna give it a
duration of 0.1 seconds
and I want to repeat the count
indefinitely so that the glow starts to
like create that pulse effect by going
in and out now I'm gonna be taking oh
I'm gonna be taking the the values of
zero to 50/50 back to zero so I want
this to be a relatively smooth animation
and so I want it to go up and then come
back down
so in the same way that you would take
and define that within your CSS you can
take and define it within the element
itself and now we have the key times and
the key splines now those respect
we are related to the keyframes and the
timing element that you want to be
applying within this CSS the key splines
are the cubic Bezier function so instead
of having the cubic Bezier defined with
four different numbers you take and have
it within the matrix itself also happy
to explain that math - a little bit
later and then from there we want to
take and squish all of these effects
together with the FE composit element
itself and so you're gonna take the
original source graphic you're gonna
take the result which we had defined
espect 1 and you're gonna merge them
together and from there that's how you
create these like awesome effects but
again you want to be able to define that
right at the beginning and so that's
kind of part of the part of the
discussion so now we're gonna move on to
one of the other ones that I really like
and so this is that same point light
you're applying but now I'm applying an
actual animate element to it and taking
and moving the light across the plane
the X plane back and forth across the
page and so one of the things that
you'll see within here is on the right
hand side the light actually goes off of
the canvas itself so you're applying a
negative value to that whereas you want
to be starting if you want to be
starting right at zero you'll see that
it hits the limits of the actual box and
so within here I've defined the filter
of the spot light moving I will open
this hopefully it works okay super so
again we're taking in applying the
effect we're giving it an ID now what's
happening in here is we were applying a
blur effect to the to the original
source graphic itself we're calling that
result by applying a standard deviation
of to blur one from there we are taking
and that end results and we're putting
it into the next filter that we want to
be creating and we're calling the
results of
that SPECT 1 from there I'm taking and
adding a special specular exponent so
remember in that first example that we
had with the light where we had a really
high or really low value of the light
and so within this particular SVG the
light source is actually really narrow
and I'm applying a lighting color of
just off-white okay um I'll wrap it up
real quick then from there I'm taking
and defining where within this cube I
actually want this light source to be
living okay from there I want to animate
the point light itself so I want it to
be going across the X plane then from
all of that I'm gonna take and merge
everything together into one SVG and so
this particular effect it takes the
original source graphic and it takes the
results of the other three effects that
we had applied and it merges it all into
one does that make sense
super okay so let's talk about browser
support hahaha the fun part you know
what I crushing all of our souls so
there is this lovely lady called Sarah
Dresner she says that smell is dead
so smell is the EFI goes on blur the
epic opposite the inline elements that
you can utilize right now it still works
in the browser it still works across
chrome if you go to can I use it has
pretty good support okay however and
like a lot of the effects that I showed
you before they also have really good
support but if you want to be using this
across browsers there's a library called
G SAP or green sock that you can utilize
and you can take and apply those exact
same effects using their library and
it'll add a polyfill and you can utilize
it across multiple browsers it is using
Java scripts you wouldn't actually be
using this with the inline
SVG elements that I was showing you
earlier but again like all that's up on
the code pen so if you guys want to play
around with it like you're more than
welcome to Oh
for those of you that code Andrew
because I code in Ruby I found this Ruby
helper a few years ago and I thought it
was just epic and you can just take and
call whatever the original SVG element
it is and that's it thank you we got
five minutes if anybody has any
questions guys can grill me yeah right
so his question was is it better to have
the component rendered over and over and
over again or is it better within like
the react or is it better to have it
defined once and just utilize the use
element and so in that case that you're
talking about I usually will put that
component within the footer because the
footer is never going to disappear and
so from there I can take and call the
use element across the entire ecosystem
of my react application and the icons
will render the same does that answer
your question kind of sort of we can
talk more about it after if you want do
I have any other questions no super see
you guys later thank you
[Applause]